je suis heureux c'est génial qu'à new
york que vous puissiez obtenir votre
vaccin pour les plus jeunes
donc je viens de recevoir ma première
dose maintenant comme ah oui un
américain sur trois a reçu au moins une
dose un vaccin contre le coc vie 19 et
les etats unis comptent bien donner un
nouveau coup d'accélérateur à leur
campagne de vaccination tous les adultes
seront éligibles pour en bénéficier
d'ici au 19 avril prochain dans le pays
une campagne de vaccination qui
s'accompagne d'une polémique autour de
la mise en place ou non d'un passeport
qu'ovide numérique
new york est pour l'instant le seul des
états américains va lancer un tel passe
sur la base du volontariat un code qr
sur smartphone qui certifie qu une
personne est immunisé contre le courant
n'a virus d'autres gouverneurs s'y
opposent fermement
au nom des libertés individuelles c'est
totalement inacceptable qu'un
gouvernement que le secteur privé vous
impose de montrer une preuve de
vaccination simplement pour participer à
la société
vous voulez aller au cinéma est-ce que
vous devrez montrer ça non vous voulez
aller voir un match non vous voulez
aller dans un parc d'attractions non
nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec ça des
mots suivis d'actes s'est très
rapidement
le gouverneur de floride a signé un
décret vendredi dernier interdisant aux
services administratifs de son état de
délivrer tout passeport vaccinale
quelques jours plus tard c'est au tour
de son homologue républicain du texas
d'interdire une série d'organismes
d'exiger des preuves de vaccination et
face à la controverse politique
le gouvernement des états unis lui
affirme être toujours contre ce
passeport national le gouvernement ne
soutien pas et ne soutiendra pas un
système qui demanderait aux américains
d'avoir un certificat
il n'y aura pas de bases de données
fédérale sur les vaccinations ni
d'obligations fédérales exigent à tous
d'obtenir un certificat de vaccination
et données personnelles et les droits
des américains doivent être protégés et
donc ces systèmes ne doivent pas être
utilisés contre les gens de façon
injuste l'idée d'un passeport sanitaires
fédérales est donc écartée pour le
moment aux états unis la maison blanche
laisse cependant le secteur privé libre
d'avancer vers cette option et ce malgré
les inquiétudes grandissantes sur de
possibles
discrimination et la protection des
données privées